apple just had their 14 and 16 inch
macbook pro event and i think we can all
agree that even pc fanboys were blown
away by the m1 pro and the m1 max chips
but with that said there are 12 things
that apple hid from you
when they did that presentation that i'm
going to be sharing both some positives
and also some negatives mostly on the
negative side there's enough positives
i'm not going to waste any time telling
you guys what you already know
so let's go ahead and get into it now
with that i do want to mention that we
are working on a buyer's guide because
there are an insane amount of
configurations
different bin chips different upgrade
options so that will be coming out most
likely today as soon as it is finished
so make sure you guys hit that subscribe
button now the first thing i want to
talk about this is kind of obvious but
these are more expensive
now not just on the get-go i mean apple
showed off that 1999 dollar price for
the 14-inch but what they didn't mention
is the fact that that model is a slower
version of the chip that they showed off
on stage now yes apple has done that
before with the m1 macbook air but that
was only missing one graphics core and
they effectively dropped the price but i
think up to about a hundred and fifty
dollars less than previously they gave
you a much better performance at the
very cheapest price so we forgave them
but this time around they raised the
price by two hundred dollars compared to
the four thunderbolt port model
and that one has two less cores for the
cpu performance cores and two less
graphics cores now that means that
you're getting potentially up to 25 less
performance cores and 20 less cpu
performance compared to what they showed
off on stage and 15 less graphics
performance you actually have to spend
another 200
more to get the full eight performance
course in the 10 core cpu and another
100 on top of that or 300 more than
their 2 000 price to get the full
graphic scores that means that that is a
price increase of 500 compared to before
if you want to look at the way of you
know them binning the chips and is it
worth spending the extra maybe 200 or
300
upgrading that 14 inch from its base
price well we will have to see and we
have both ordered so make sure you guys
are subscribed if you want to see that
but with that said that is not the only
upgrade you get if you spend a little
bit more money which leads me into
number two and that is the power adapter
the batteries in this 14 inch macbook
pro got 20
larger now compared to the 13 inch
macbook pro and apple showed off being
able to fast charge from zero to 50 in
30 minutes which is great but what they
didn't mention is that you need a 96
watt charger to do that and the base
model comes with a 67 watt charger now
thankfully you don't have to buy the
next bump up the 2500
configuration to get that 96 watt
charger if you decide to upgrade even up
to the the 10 core a non-bin cpu but
still the bin graphics that includes
that 96 watt charger for no extra price
which is good but even if you don't need
any extra performance other than the
base model you can actually spend 20
dollars more to get that 96 watt charger
to be able to fast charge this machine
now personally my thought is why even
make a new 67 watt charger it's a new
charger used to be 61 watts and then let
people upgrade for 20 bucks more and
then if you upgrade anything else in
terms of performance you get that
charger anyway it seems like a waste i
think should just be included so make
sure you at least spend that 20 extra
dollars number three is just how chunky
these machines are as soon as we saw
them we're like wow these things look so
thick but in fact there are two things
that weren't mentioned both on the
positive and on the negative now the
first one is just the fact that these
machines aren't really that thick it's
just the shape that changes no longer
tapered and that's because apple's
fitting in larger batteries more
components better speakers all of that
into these so the sides are a lot more
flat making them look a lot thicker than
they are in fact the 14 inch model is
actually slightly thinner than the
previous 13 inch now on the 16 inch
model it is thicker even though apple
said it's like 16.7 millimeters thin
it is thicker but only by four percent
now we do have a bigger difference in
weight the 14 inch model actually went
up by 17
it's actually heavier than the older
13-inch macbook pros back when we had
ports but for the 16-inch model the
weight only went up by nine percent at
least the base rated weight and that
leads me into number four and that is
something that is going to be very
interesting as soon as we get our hands
on these because this could be very
significant and that is if you go for
the m1 max chip on the 16 inch the
laptop is actually heavier it goes from
4.7 pounds up to 4.8 pounds now what
really gets me is that for the 14 inch
we don't have anything like this listed
at all and this has me thinking that we
might actually have better cooling for
the 16 inch model when you upgrade to
that chip and then the 14 inch model it
is all the same which also means that we
could have thermal throttling on the 14
inch and not have it on the 16 inch
because apple has more room to play with
for the cooling now of course we did get
30 to 32 core graphics on a 14 inch and
we got a 16 inch of those graphics so we
will be putting those head to head it's
going to be very interesting to check
out the thermals if you guys want to see
that make sure you have notifications
enabled now apart from that you can
basically get the same configuration for
a 14-inch and a 16-inch model which we
have never gotten before not only were
13-inch mac pros way less powerful than
15 or 16-inch models but you couldn't
get as much ram and storage but now you
can get both of those you can get 64
gigs and an 8 terabyte ssd the new ultra
fast 7.6 gigabytes per second ssds on a
14 inch now because of that the price
difference now is very little we're
talking only 200 difference if they're
spec the same between a 14 and a 16. so
now you can actually choose do you just
want the larger size and be quiet siri
do you want the larger size you want to
spell a little bit more or would you
prefer something more compact which a
lot of people do and fun fact you can
now spend up to five thousand nine
hundred dollars on a 14-inch macbook pro
pre-tax now like i mentioned you could
get the same exact processors on both
but what apple didn't mention is that if
you want to go for an m1 max processor
you're automatically forced into getting
32 gigabytes of ram which you never had
to do before and that costs
automatically an extra bump of 400 not
counting the extra money for the
processor itself now don't get bumped
out about these higher prices right away
because you can actually save money with
these new machines in two different ways
just yesterday if you wanted to get the
best cpu and the best graphics with a
one terabyte ssd 32 gigs of ram which
that's what a lot of people buy that
actually costs four thousand and one
hundred dollars but today if you want
the same configuration with the best cpu
and the best graphics you will spend
three thousand five hundred dollars
meaning you actually save six hundred
bucks
and you get a much better machine and
the second part of this that you have to
keep in mind is even the 16 core base
graphics for the 16 inch those are more
powerful than the 5600 m that you would
spend 4
hundred dollars on and with that unified
memory is much more efficient than the
standard memory and the new ssds are
more than twice as fast so a lot of you
guys that had to buy 32 gigs of ram you
no longer have to spend that amount of
money so if you count it this way a two
thousand seven hundred dollar sixteen
inch will be faster way faster than that
four thousand one hundred dollar model
now of course because the 14 inch can
support the same configuration if you
don't want the larger size if 14.2
inches is enough for you you can save
another 200
meaning a macbook this year can be up to
a thousand six hundred dollars less
expensive than the one you bought last
time and a lot more powerful with extra
ports much better displays
better speakers webcam all of that or a
thousand four hundred dollars less
expensive if you still wanna stick with
that 16 inch size now number nine is
that 24 core graphics configuration that
they completely didn't mention during
their keynote they talked about the 16
core and the 32 but as we see on the
configurator we have that now what you
might think is that hey
you're spending only 200 more than the
16 core only half what the 32 core
option costs and maybe it's worth that
for eight extra graphics scores or maybe
it's worth spending more but one thing
that most people don't know is that if
you choose that option you pay 200 more
if you're already getting that amount of
ram that it requires you're getting way
more than eight cores you are getting
not only double the encoders and
decoders which means that exporting
video will be twice as fast even if you
don't need the extra raw performance but
with that you're getting support for
twice the amount of external displays as
well and up to twice the memory
bandwidth as well so for an extra 200
more that just might be the best bang
for the buck configuration because this
is an m1 max chip that is binned that
means that it's using the same cooler as
the 32 core with probably either better
heat pipes or more conductivity to cover
that much larger
m1 max chip meaning that it can actually
run cooler and quieter potentially than
the 16 core definitely cooler and
quieter than the 32 core so this might
just be the ultimate configuration and i
got to tell you we ordered not only a 16
core and a 32 but also a 24. i spent way
too much money but we will see how these
compare once we get these and i'm
extremely excited to test them out now
something that's a little bit less
exciting definitely a bummer is the fact
that these new chips still have no
support for wi-fi 6e which was actually
announced and certified almost two years
ago and no bluetooth 5.2 so it's still
just standard wi-fi 6 and bluetooth 5.0
and that's a bummer because unlike
phones which people upgrade every year
or maybe two years every three years
some people most people will keep their
laptops for five six seven years a long
time and wi-fi six e has support for the
six gigahertz band which has a lot less
issues with other people's wi-fi you
have better bandwidth so that definitely
is a bummer for me the apple did not
update it and it's still using the old
standard and with that the next thing
the apple didn't tell you is that the
hdmi port that they finally put back in
it's very convenient that it's there it
is not using the latest hdmi 2.0
technology now this makes no sense to me
because this port is limited to 4k 60
hertz like we had years and years ago
five six years ago now instead of being
able to support 4k 120 hertz or 8k
support through that port now the weird
thing for me is that the new apple tv 4k
that came out this year that cost 180
that thing supports hdmi 2.1 where this
macbook pro does not and if you want to
support higher frame rates high
resolutions you are still going to have
to connect through the thunderbolt port
and that hdmi is just going to be a
waste there now the last one that i want
to cover is battery life the 16 inch one
has great battery life but unfortunately
the 14 inch model even though the
battery is 20
larger the battery life is only slightly
better than the older intel macbook pros
by one hour of web use now man i was
like why is this so poor here we have
the bigger battery well of course we
have the much higher resolution displays
that are much brighter we're supporting
pro motion there we have much more
performance with the cpu and the
graphics and because this is a 10 core
chip
apple uh they got rid of two of the
efficiency cores so instead of four
efficiency cores and four performance
cores with the m1 we now have two
efficiency cores and six performance
cores for the non-binned model so there
you guys go those are 12 things that
apple did not mention at their event of
course we are making that buyer's guide
telling you guys which mistakes you
should not make when you're ordering and
which specifications and configurations
we recommend for certain use cases if
you guys want to see that click that
subscribe button above and with that you
guys can help us reach our goal of 1
million subscribers check out one of
those great videos right over there this
is max and i'll see you in the next
video
[Music]